ladies and gentlemen 2020 has changed
the world the new coronavirus impacted
the lives of hundreds of millions of
people private companies and government
agencies this spring saw an almost
fivefold increase in the number of
Russians working remotely many of them
will continue to operate out of their
homes even after the pandemic is over
self-isolation made us even more
dependent on digital undisrupted digital
delivery of public services has become
of principal importance this is why our
priority is focused towards ensuring the
digital safety of our people in the last
decades our digital reliance progressed
as public and private operators
increasingly used digital technologies
to improve their efficiency development
of internet led to openness and
interconnectivity thus multiplying the
benefits from using digital technologies
however the same technologies have
exposed human society to new threats
malicious actors are increasingly
innovative geopolitical tensions extend
to digital environment adding states to
the list of the possible digital
security threat sources security
researchers are repeatedly identifying
sophisticated malware specially designed
to disrupt critical functions and cause
physical damage to industries and
infrastructure according to the OECD
these threats are pressing governments
to adopt policies that strengthen
digital security of critical activities
without undermining the benefits from
digital transformation in critical
sectors that would unnecessarily
restrict the use and openness of digital
technology the national level action
plan of our government aimed at
supporting the post crisis recovery of
the Russian economy is based on the
increasing digitalization of economy in
we will drastically increase the number
of available digital public services and
introduced fundamentally new support
measures for digital businesses in this
context one of the most essential tasks
is to ensure the protection of
cyberspace the spring we witnessed a
rise in the cyber criminal activity over
90% of successful cybercrime attacks
conducted using social engineering
criminals charged their attacks using
phishing emails and the caller ID
spoofing putting our citizen off guard
in cooperation with the Russian IT
security companies the government is
working on improving awareness of cyber
risks and threats among our people
thanks to the joint efforts we managed
to address a considerable amount of the
issues however many problems still
require our attention another current
challenge for all global economies is
confidential data theft
therefore we pay special attention to
improving data security russia has
developed a common national system for
identifying and prevention of
cyberattacks with the government
agencies information systems linked into
the system we introduced strict
protocols to secure connection of
schools and other social institutions to
Internet network secure networks
environments are being created to
connect educational healthcare and
social protection institutions the
entire international community has to
stand together to prevent global cyber
fraud pandemic promoting international
cooperation is an area of key focus of
our joint efforts to ensure digital
security and provide a common response
to cybercrime our country is a leader in
the technology development Russian
digital security solutions are
successfully presented at in
national markets the government is
providing grants to support development
and pilot implementation of such
promising technologies as quantum
cryptography we also appreciate the
importance of international knowledge
exchange and are ready to share our
developments with our partners ensuring
security of our common future requires
open and balanced dialogue and we are
open to cooperation I am therefore
pleased to see the leaders of large
international organization including the
World Economic Forum and Interpol as
well as the CEOs of the global
corporations from a wide range of the
industries in the countries at this
event this training is another step in
creating a trusted digital environment
and fostering open dialogue to discuss
even the most challenging cybersecurity
issues let me wish success to all the
participants of the cyber polygons
training and I thank you for you good
work today
you are making your contribution to
building a more secure digital vault and
safer future for all of us thank you
ladies and gentlemen 2020 has changed
the world the new coronavirus impacted
the lives of hundreds of millions of
people private companies and government
agencies this spring saw an almost
fivefold increase in the number of
Russians working remotely many of them
will continue to operate out of their
homes even after the in pandemic is over
self-isolation
made us even more dependent on digital
undisrupted digital delivery of public
services has become of principal
importance this is why our priority is
focused towards ensuring the digital
safety of our people in the last decades
our digital reliance progressed as
public and private operators
increasingly used digital technologies
to improve their efficiency development
of Internet led to openness and
interconnectivity thus multiplying the
benefits from using digital technologies
however the same technologies have
exposed human society to new threats
malicious actors are increasingly
innovative geopolitical tensions extend
to digital environment adding states to
the list of the possible digital
security threat sources security
researchers are repeatedly identifying
sophisticated malware specially designed
to disrupt critical functions and cause
physical damage to industries and
infrastructure according to the OECD
these threats are pressing government's
to adopt policies that strengthen
digital security of critical activities
without undermining the benefits from
digital transformation in critical
sectors that would unnecessarily
restrict the use and openness of digital
technology the national level action
plan of our government aimed at
supporting the post crisis recovery of
the Russian economy is based on the
increasing digitalization of economy and
we will drastically increase the number
of available digital public services and
introduced fundamentally new support
measures for digital businesses in this
context one of the most essential tasks
is to ensure the protection of
cyberspace the spring we witnessed a
rise in the cyber criminal activity over
90% of successful cybercrime attacks
conducted using social engineering
criminals charge their attacks using
phishing emails and the caller ID
spoofing putting our citizen of guard in
cooperation with the Russian IT security
companies the government is working on
improving awareness of cyber risks and
threats among our people thanks to the
joint efforts we managed to address a
considerable amount of the issues
however many problems still require our
attention another current challenge for
all global economies is confidential
data theft
therefore we pay special attention to
improving data security russia has
developed a common national system for
identifying and prevention of
cyberattacks with the government
agencies information systems linked into
the system we introduced strict
protocols to secure connection of
schools and other social institutions to
Internet network secure networks
environments are being created to
connect educational healthcare and
social protection institutions the
entire international community has to
stand together to prevent global cyber
fraud pandemic promoting international
cooperation is an area of key focus of
our joint efforts to ensure digital
security and provide a common response
to cybercrime our country is a leader in
the technology development Russian
digital security solutions are
successfully presented at international
markets the government is providing
Reince to support development and pilot
implementation of such promising
technologies as quantum cryptography
we also appreciate the importance of
international knowledge exchange and are
ready to share our developments with our
partners ensuring security of our common
future requires open and balanced
dialogue and we are open to cooperation
I am therefore pleased to see the
leaders of large international
organization including the World
Economic Forum and Interpol as well as
the CEOs of the global corporations from
a wide range of the industries in the
countries at this event this training is
another step in creating a trusted
digital environment and fostering open
dialogue to discuss even the most
challenging cybersecurity issues let me
wish success to all the participants of
the cyber polygons training and I thank
you for you good work today you are
making your contribution to building a
more secure digital vault and safer
future for all of us thank you
you